so the question is after a full year of
watching these people lie in order to
imprison a kid for the rest of his life
who's going to hold the liars
accountable kyle rittenhouse
understandably has thought a lot about
this he joins us tonight to explain his
plan going forward kyle thanks so much
for coming on tonight i can't think of
many people who've been at the receiving
end of this much sinister lying from
so-called news organizations as you have
how are you going to respond
well tucker thank you for having me um
of course me and my team have decided to
launch the media accountability project
as a tool to help fundraise and hold the
media accountable for the lies they said
and deal with them in court
interesting so the idea is
maybe like the covington catholic kids
you will be suing news organizations
that maliciously lie about people who
are in the news is that the plan
yes sir we're going to be holding them
accountable tucker
do you exp i mean i guess i have to ask
a kind of a dumb question but you know
why isn't there a group like this that
exists already since the media so often
are not observers they're players
they're participants
in the news
why hasn't someone done this before
that's a good question tucker and i'm
not sure to be honest but
i don't want to see anybody else have to
deal with what i went through so i want
to hold them accountable for what they
did to me because i don't want to see
anybody have to go through what i went
through
yeah i mean they tried to imprison you
for the rest of your life it wasn't
coverage it was advocacy you have a lot
of potential targets to sue yourself
will you be suing any of these news
organizations and if so when
um well right now we're looking at quite
a few
politicians celebrities athletes
whoopi goldbergs on the list she called
me a murderer
after i was acquitted by a jury of my
peers she went on to still say that
and there's others don't forget about
sank from the young turks he called me a
murderer before verdict and continues to
call me a murderer
interesting and and what about the
people who called you groundlessly a
white supremacist which makes it pretty
hard to get a job for the rest of your
life if you're a white supremacist
will you be responding to them
absolutely we are going to hold
everybody who's lied about me
accountable
such as
everybody who's lied called me a white
supremacist
yeah they're all going to be held
accountable and we're going to handle
them in a courtroom
car written house i appreciate you
announcing that tonight the media
accountability project and of course
we're rooting for justice as we always
are so thank you very much good to see
you thank you tucker and if anybody
wants to help join us in this battle
they can donate at tmap.org
thanks a lot
so of course we documented the whole
written house trial was on our
documentary series tucker carlson
originals we had behind the scenes
access
during that the episode is called the
trial of kyle we're proud of it it's
available on fox nation you get it free
on tuckercarlson.com
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else